[APPLAUSE]
FRANCES PERRY: So, welcome.
Today we're going to be
talking about data processing
and open source-- in
particular, how Google
is helping shape the future.
So my name is Francis
Perry, and I'm a data
processing infrastructure geek.
I love figuring
out the right way
to take a really complex and
powerful data processing system
and make it extremely
intuitive and easy to use.
JAMES MALONE: Good evening.
I'm James Malone.
I'm a product manager
here at Google.
I'm fascinated by data,
because data is everywhere.
I'm also really passionate
about open source software,
because I think it
shows what people
can do when they work
together to collectively solve
really challenging problems.
What's really
interesting to me is
when they can work together,
both data and open source.
So today, we're going to talk
about the next generation
of data processing.
We're going to go
boldly where many have
gone before with mixed success.
What we want to do
is we want to lay out
a meaningful vision for open
source, next generation data
processing.
We'll start by looking
at now, challenges
today, the challenges
that exist today
that should not exist tomorrow.
We'll then launch into
MapReduce and its influences
on the challenges
of today and how
it sets the stage for next
generation data processing
tomorrow.
Next, we'll look at solutions
that exist inside of Google
right now that can help
you solve data challenges.
And finally, we'll
talk about something
that's new and exciting--
Apache Beam-- how Google
can bring its experience and
work with the open source
community to solve next
generation data processing
problems.
First, let's create
a foundation.
Let's frame the discussion
of next generation data
processing.
So I work in Seattle,
and Frances and I
were given a template.
And the slides may
look somewhat familiar
at this point in the day.
And I had one thought when I
saw this slide-- I don't have
enough vitamin D, and
I am definitely working
in the wrong Google office.
I absolutely want to work there.
It's gorgeous.
But if I were you, what
I would be wondering
is-- and we're talking
about next generation data
processing.
What things specifically,
what challenges
do we need to solve for in
order to end up in a space
where we can say we are in next
generation data processing?
We think there are
three specific things.
Now, infrastructure
can sometimes be hard.
Now, creating unified, batch,
and streaming data processing
pipelines can be challenging.
Now, the portability
of those data pipelines
can be a real pain.
First, management.
Now, the emergence of open
source data processing
tools that allow you to
process large amounts of data
in parallel-- the Apache Hadoop
and Apache Spark ecosystems
are a great example-- they're
both a blessing and a curse.
They allow you to set
up an environment where
you can decide on a tool, you
can read the documentation,
you can get your
infrastructure, you can then
set that infrastructure up,
you can set up your tools.
But then you have
to tune the tools.
You often have to
find experts who
can help you adjust all of
the knobs on those tools.
You have to productionalize
your environment.
Even though the tools
exist, and they're awesome--
they're very
powerful and they're
great to use-- they
can be very difficult.
And by the end of the
day, you are probably
now a team of people
supporting both infrastructure
and software when your end
goal at the end of the day
was to simply process a lot of
data that's important to you.
But next, this should no longer
be the case in the future.
We think it should be
very similar to using
a tool in the toolbox.
You should be able
to open the toolbox,
pick out the tool you need,
not have to assemble the tool
and forge the iron
and tune everything.
You should know how to use the
tool intuitively, or even just
watch a simple YouTube
video to get it,
and then carry away
and solve your problem.
FRANCES PERRY: Now,
the second thing
that we think is
really important
for the future of
data processing
is the right set of
abstractions, how you represent
your data processing pipeline.
As data processing needs have
become more sophisticated,
users often find that they have
to write a traditional batch
system for correct
results and also
use a different streaming system
to get more real time updates.
Now, this bifurcation
means you have
to write twice as much code.
You have to maintain twice
as much infrastructure
and somehow reconcile
these two different results
into one conceptual output.
Now, we think if we can find the
right way to represent our data
processing pipelines, we can
handle both batch and streaming
use cases in the
same unified system.
And the final
thing that we think
is going to change the future of
data processing is portability.
Many current systems
tightly couple
the code for expressing your
logic with the implementation
of the service itself.
So that means if you want
to move your application
from Hadoop to Spark or
from on-premise to cloud,
you have to rewrite
large portions
of that logic in a
different framework,
and then you have to dive in
and find what the right tuning
knobs are in this new scenario.
So we can break that cycle.
Again, if we find that right
abstraction, that right model,
you'll be able to write your
application logic once and run
it multiple places.
JAMES MALONE: So ultimately,
you might be asking, great.
So you're identified three
things-- management, model,
and portability.
But why do these matter?
Why are these the things
that you have picked?
Why are these the problems
that we need to solve for,
and what are the impacts on
me today and in the future?
I'm going to use a metaphor.
Say you have a rental car.
And many of you may
have gotten a rental car
when you traveled here.
You trust that the rental car
agency has managed the car.
You don't have to pop the
hood and check the oil
level every time you
get a new rental car.
You also are familiar with
the controls of a car,
so you don't need to learn a
new set of controls every time
you get a rental car.
And while you're traveling
in the United States,
most signs are
relatively the same,
and you trust that
the car will drive
on different types of roads.
So you have the portability.
You can drive on the freeway.
You can drive on country roads.
You can drive on city streets.
There's no problems there.
Ultimately, why
it matters to you
is when you are wrangling
with the infrastructure
and the tooling to solve
complicated data problems,
you are focusing on the
infrastructure and the tooling,
and you're not focusing
on what matters
to you the most-- your data.
These are not new challenges.
And in fact, a lot
of the challenges
have existed for
quite some time.
They're really hard
problems to solve, however.
So let's start with
a little history.
Because MapReduce is
a solution to some
of these problems
which has influenced
the present and
potentially the future.
FRANCES PERRY: All right.
So back in the early days,
Google, like many other folks,
needed to process a lot of data.
However, conventional
tools and methods
couldn't keep up with
the growth of this data,
so engineers ended up
spending their time
writing custom computations
to handle each particular use
case.
Now, if there's one
thing engineers hate,
it's wasting time,
particularly on something
that can be automated.
So the engineers started looking
for a generalized solution
for specifying logic
that runs in parallel
across many machines.
At the same time, they wanted to
shield the author of that logic
from dealing with
low-level details,
like moving data from
one machine to another
and handling fault tolerance.
So Jeff and Sanjay settled
on a simple reusable pattern.
You take your data set, and
you partition it into chunks.
Then you take each
chunk and hand it
out to a different
mapping machine.
A mapping machine
takes its chunk
and runs a piece of
user-provided logic
over that chunk to
process each element.
Now, each of those chunks
is processed independently
on a different machine, so
this makes it extremely easy
to parallelize.
Once the mapping
machines are done,
they redistribute their
data across multiple
reducing machines based
on a key of the data.
And then finally, each reducing
machine-- again, independently
from other reducing machines--
runs another bit of user logic
to create these final outputs.
Together, this is your
output collection.
Now, the beautiful
thing about this pattern
is it's extremely powerful.
You can take pretty much
any big data processing
algorithm that you want, and
you can run it in MapReduce.
You might have to
take your algorithm
and completely convolute
it beyond any recognition,
but you can shove it
into that framework
if you try hard enough.
So in 2004, Google published
a paper on MapReduce.
And at this point, things
diverge a little bit.
Inside Google, we
kept innovating.
But we were doing this in
a relatively homogeneous
environment, so we
had only a few file
formats we were dealing with.
We had a limited
number of languages
that we needed to
support, and we had
extremely standardized tooling.
So this meant that we got
to spend our time focusing
on really refining
our core methodology
and generating new
ideas on how we would
want to process this data.
So we continued to publish
papers on these new ideas.
And from the external community,
folks saw a lot of PDFs
popping up-- a lot of
good things to read,
but nothing concrete
that you could actually
get your hands on and play with.
Now, at the same time,
externally in the open source
community, we had a different
implementation of MapReduce
inside Hadoop.
And an entire data processing
ecosystem developed here.
Some of this continued to be
published by the Google papers,
but there was also a
lot of new innovation
that happened here on its own
in this very diverse system.
So today, Google Cloud
Platform contains
two systems, two products
that come from this MapReduce
lineage.
The first one is
Google Cloud data flow.
And this is a
fully-managed cloud service
that evolved directly
from MapReduce
and includes some of these
later ideas from Google,
like FlumeJava's clean
abstractions and MillWheel's
focus on streaming and
real-time execution.
Now, for those users who
have a significant investment
in open source
technologies already,
we have Google Cloud
Dataproc, which
is a fully-managed
service for executing
Hadoop in Spark programs.
James.
JAMES MALONE: Thank you.
So let's take a look at the
first product in the Google
Cloud Platform portfolio
that's based directly-- quite
literally-- on MapReduce--
Google Cloud Dataproc.
So as Frances mentioned,
the Apache Hadoop ecosystem
evolved directly as
an implementation
of the MapReduce white paper.
And arguably, it's had just--
I apologize-- unarguably,
it has had an enormous impact
on the current state and future
of data processing.
It allows people to solve
really hard data problems that
weren't possible before.
It has the models.
It has tools.
It has the community.
It's really made a change
in how people process data.
But a lot of these tools
also come with their own set
of challenges.
And this is true
for Apache Spark.
It's true for Apache Hadoop.
In general, a lot
of open source tools
share these three
common problems.
First, installation--
they can be a real pain
to install and configure.
Second, they can be
really tricky to run
at a cost-effective scale.
Third, typically, you
have to know quite a bit
about all of these
different components
to use them effectively.
Well, Google has been running
MapReduce and other data
processing technologies
at scale for a long time.
So why not leverage all of
this existing investment
infrastructure and knowledge
to create a product?
Well, we did, and
Cloud Dataproc is
the answer to that challenge.
It brings the familiar
Spark and Hadoop ecosystem
to the Google Cloud platform.
This is great for
moving existing code
that you've already developed
in on-premise or other cloud
environments or a
brand new development.
And if you're familiar with
the Spark and Hadoop ecosystem,
there's a wealth
of different tools
that fit into that ecosystem.
Cloud Dataproc ultimately helps
solve the thorniest management
headaches that usually follow
the Apache Spark and Hadoop
ecosystem.
It really focuses on
speed, simplicity, and cost
effectiveness.
Cloud Dataproc is designed
as an ephemeral solution.
And ultimately, what
we mean by that is we
want you to have clusters
when you need them,
when you actually
have work to do,
and we want you to be
able to turn them off
when you don't need them.
We don't want you to have to
carry excess idle capacity when
it makes no sense to you.
So we like to think
of Cloud Dataproc
as combining the
power of Google,
both in software and hardware,
with the power of open source.
So ultimately, what
is Cloud Dataproc?
It's best to think about
Cloud Dataproc as two
top-level concepts--
clusters and jobs.
Cloud Dataproc
clusters ultimately
are a layer cake of
three big components.
The first-- Cloud Dataproc
is built on the power
of Google Cloud Platform.
This means the virtual machines
that you use for your cluster,
our Google Compute
Engine machines,
you can connect to
Google Cloud Storage.
So we use the already-existing
tools available to us.
We then have an agent that
runs on top of this cluster.
It's really the glue between
the underlying Google Cloud
Services and the open source
tools that live on a cluster.
The agent is doing
all of the things,
like tuning the 500 to 600
different knobs that exist
in Spark and Hadoop alone.
And finally, we have
the open source tools.
This is Spark.
This is Hadoop.
This is Hive.
This is Pig.
The second top-level concept
in Cloud Dataproc are jobs.
And we provide a
set of tools which
abstract the pain of trying to
manage workflows away from you
to create an
abstraction layer where
you can run some of
the most popular job
types on your cluster without
having to open terminal windows
or know how Spark
Submit works, which
means you can submit Spark,
PySpark, Spark SQL, Pig, Hive,
Java MapReduce, all
without actually having
to ever log into a cluster.
You can simply create
a cluster in one click
and run your job in
your second click.
That's it.
Cloud Dataproc is
also not isolated.
It doesn't stand alone.
And this is a very
important point,
because it means that you
can read and write data
to many different places.
You can read and write data
from other GCP products.
You can read and write
data to Dataproc jobs,
both on the same
cluster, or since it's
an ephemeral solution and you
can create clusters quickly,
any other cluster.
You could also feed data
to other applications
on the cluster.
So we give you the ability
to install other open source
components-- for example,
Apache Zeppelin on the cluster--
so your spark can be talking
to Zeppelin all on one cluster
easily.
I want to go to the
point about Dataproc
talking to other Google
Cloud Platform products,
because this is a
very important point.
It allows you to use the
familiar Spark and Hadoop
ecosystem that you may already
have knowledge, existing code,
documentation,
tooling, and use it
with the other powerful tools
in the Google Cloud Platform
portfolio.
For example, you could
have a PySpark job
which reads data from
Google Cloud Storage,
processes the data with Spark
using PySpark and potentially
all of your favorite
Python libraries,
and then output the resultant
data set to BigQuery.
Google Cloud
Dataproc is designed
to bring the
experience and power
of this very familiar
ecosystem to the integrated and
comprehensive
processing platform
provided by Google
Cloud Platform.
I want to back up some
of the things I'm saying
and not just say that Google
Cloud Dataproc is fast, easy,
and cost effective.
I want to give some
specific points
to actually elaborate
on why that is the case.
So let's start with speed.
On average, Cloud
Dataproc clusters
start in about 90 seconds
for your average cluster.
They also stop in
about the same time.
That's really important.
Because if you have an
ephemeral cluster that you're
creating precisely
when you need it,
it means you spend less time
waiting for your cluster
to become available.
You also aren't paying for
your cluster to start and stop.
Second, clusters can
be resized at any time.
So if you have a series of big
jobs, you can add more nodes.
When you're done, you
can remove the nodes.
And Cloud Dataproc will
handle all of the brokerage
in trying to commission
and decommission nodes
without causing
your jobs to fail.
We also don't
bloat the clusters.
So we include vanilla versions
of Spark, Hadoop, Hive,
Pig, and a few other
components, but we're not
putting on software extras
that we think you might not
need which are going to slow the
cluster down or just complicate
your use of the cluster.
Ease of use-- so as I mentioned
when I was talking about jobs,
we provide a job wrapper
which allows you to send jobs
to the cluster, monitor jobs.
You can stream the
output of drivers
without ever opening
an SSH window.
You can do it in a browser.
You can do it with Python.
You can do it with any
number of libraries.
You can do through a REST API.
That also means we have
several surface areas
that you can use to interact
with Cloud Dataproc,
including our Google Developers
console, the Google Cloud
SDK, REST APIs, and
at the end of the day,
since this is built
on Compute Engine
and it is vanilla Spark and
Hadoop, if you want to go SSH
into clusters, go wild.
You totally can.
And finally, optimized for
cost-- I have never really met
a Spark or Hadoop job which runs
specifically to one hour or two
hours or three hours.
Typically, it's a fraction
or a subset of hours.
We bill Cloud
Dataproc by the minute
with a 10-minute minimum.
This means that if your
job runs for 28 minutes,
you pay for 28
minutes, not one hour.
And when you're creating large
clusters with potentially tens
or hundreds of nodes, this
can be absolutely substantial.
We also priced
Cloud Dataproc based
on the size of your cluster
and the number of virtual CPUs.
So it's easy to understand, and
doing the cost calculation is
fairly straightforward.
And finally, you can
use preemptables and now
custom machine types as
part of our GA of last month
that allow you to
very carefully craft
the size of your cluster based
on the needs of your data
processing pipeline.
That means that you can
articulate your cluster
specifically so you aren't over
or under-consuming resources.
So going back to
the three things
that Frances and
I are discussing
today that are really
important problems that
need to be solved for
next generation data
processing-- Cloud Dataproc
addresses one of them
head on-- management.
We have really tried to
solve the thorny management
problems that exist with
some of the open source tools
so you don't have
to worry about them.
But there are other services
in the Google Cloud platform
portfolio that go a
little bit further,
and Cloud Dataflow
is one of them.
FRANCES PERRY: Thanks, James.
So let's dive in to more
details on Cloud Dataflow.
Now, this is the path
that came out of MapReduce
and is based on a bunch
of continued innovation
internally at Google.
Now it's available to
you as a cloud product,
and there are two key
advantages to Cloud Dataflow.
The first benefit is
the programming model.
This is the way
that we encourage
you to write dataflow programs.
This is the way that you
represent your business logic,
and you focus on that--
your application logic,
not how you cram that logic into
some underlying infrastructure.
Instead, you're
building a pipeline.
Your pipeline contains a mix of
custom element-wise processing,
aggregations, and
library functions.
Dataflow pipelines can process
both bounded, fixed size data
sets, like we're used to in
traditional batch systems,
but it can also handle
infinite streams of data.
And when you're writing
that application logic that
becomes your Dataflow
pipeline, you
don't have to wonder about
what type of collection
you're running over.
Your logic will
apply equally well
to both bounded and
unbounded data sets.
This means that you have
a lot of flexibility
in how you write
your logic, and it
can be reusable in many
different scenarios.
Now, to truly unify batch and
streaming into a single system,
we need to separate the
notion of event time
from processing time.
Event time is a time an
event actually happened.
So let's say we have a
mobile gaming application.
Users are on their cellphones
all over the world,
frantically doing something.
They're popping
balloons, crushing candy,
whatever it is they're doing.
It's happening everywhere.
And we want to process those
points of their scoring
and figure out
information about that.
So the time the user crushed the
candy-- that's the event time.
The processing time
is the time when
that score is available in
our system for processing.
Ideally, those would
be the same thing,
but distributed systems
never cooperate.
So there's actually
usually quite a difference.
So here, we've got a
sample data set of points
that a specific team
scored in our game.
So on the x-axis, you
can see the event time.
Again, this is the time
the point was scored.
And on the y-axis, we
have processing time.
So if distributed systems
weren't actually a problem,
everything would appear
along this dashed line.
Something would happen,
and immediately, you
would be able to process
it in our system.
Sometimes, things aren't so bad.
So this event here happened
right before 12:07.
And just after 12:07, it's
available in our system
for processing.
So maybe there was just
a small network delay.
Other times, it's worse, though.
So this event over here
is seven minutes delayed
from when it happened
before we can process it.
Perhaps this user was playing
our game in an elevator
or in a subway, somewhere
where they had a temporary lack
of network connectivity.
We had to wait for this user
to reestablish a connection
before that event was able
to be ingested to our system
and processed.
The margins of this
graph aren't nearly wide
enough to contain what would
happen if our game supported
an offline mode.
Now we could have users
playing our mobile game
on a transatlantic flight
while they're in airplane mode.
It might be hours until
users land, reconnect,
and those events are
available for processing.
So as you can start
to see, these types
of infinite
out-of-order data sets
are really, really
tricky to reason about--
unless you know the
right questions to ask.
The dataflow model
itself revolves
around four key questions.
The first one is what
results are calculated.
What is that algorithm
that you're actually doing?
Are you computing sums, joins,
histograms, machine learning
models?
Where in event time
are results calculated?
So how does the time when
each event actually occurs
affect your overall results?
Are we aggregating
events over all time,
for fixed windows
of time, or based
on bursts of user activity?
When in processing time
are results materialized?
So that's asking, does the
time each element arrives
in the system and actually
get available for processing,
does that affect results?
How do we know when
to emit results?
What do we do when
data comes in late
and we've already
emitted the result?
And finally, the fourth question
is how do refinements relate.
So if we start emitting multiple
results because new values are
coming in and we're
changing our mind,
what do we do with each
of those new copies?
How do they interact?
So let's take a look at how we
use these questions to build
a simple pipeline.
So here's a snippet
from our pipeline.
We are processing those scoring
results from our mobile gaming
application.
In yellow, you see
the computation
that we're performing, the
first question, the what.
Here we're taking
team score pairs
of these scores that
happened, and we're
going to sum them per team.
We want to find out the
total score per team.
So right now, this is a
pretty simple pipeline.
And let's see what
happens if we execute it.
So in this looping
animation, again, you
see our axes of event
time and processing time.
And that gray line
represents processing time
as it progresses.
As the pipeline executes
and encounters elements,
they're accumulated into
that intermediate state,
shown in white.
And finally, when
processing completes,
we emit the result in yellow.
So this is just how a batch
pipeline would execute.
It's pretty standard.
But as we address some of
the next few questions,
this is going to
get more powerful.
The first thing we're
going to play with
is this notion of event time.
So we'll start by specifying
a windowing function.
By doing this, we can
calculate independent results
for different slices
of event time.
So we could compute something
for every minute, every hour,
every day.
In this case, we're going to
use two-minute chunks of time
and ask for a different sum
per team every two minutes.
So now if we look at
how things execute,
you can see that
based on event time,
we're calculating four
independent results.
Every two-minute
slice of event time
is going to give us
a different result.
Now, at this point,
we're still waiting
for the entire
computation to complete
before we emit any results.
And this works OK
if we're dealing
with a bounded, fixed-size
data set that will eventually
finish processing.
But it's not going
to work if we're
processing an infinite
amount of data,
because we'll never actually
complete and produce results.
So there, what we need to
do is reduce the latency
of individuals results.
And we do that by
asking for results
to be triggered-- triggered
based on the system's best
estimate of data completion.
We call this estimate
the watermark.
It's the way the
system estimates it.
At this point, it's
pretty much seen
all the data it's going to see
for this portion of event time.
So now I've drawn the watermark
on our graph in green.
And you can see that as
the results for each window
passes the watermark and we
think we've pretty much got all
the data, we go ahead
and admit the result.
But again, this watermark
is just a heuristic.
It's the system's best guess
about data completeness,
and guessing in a
distributed system
is going to be a bad idea.
Right now, the water
mark is too fast.
We're moving on before
we have all the data.
So in that first window,
we thought we were done.
But then that user who was
offline in the elevator
finally reconnects,
and we realize
we've got some late data, and it
just gets missed in this case.
That user is out of luck.
Their team is never going
to benefit from that score.
Now, we could be slower
and more conservative
with our watermark.
But if we do that,
we might have to wait
an unrealistic amount of time.
So if we're dealing with those
offline users on the airplane,
we're going to have to
wait till every flight
everywhere lands just in case
there was somebody in seat 26b
who was playing our game.
So that's not
reasonable, either.
We need to be able to deal
with this type of heuristic,
best effort watermark
and work around it.
So we do that by using a
more sophisticated trigger.
So now we're requesting both
early speculative firings--
so as results are
trickling in, we're
asking for tentative
updates as we go.
And also, we're asking for late
firings or additional updates
if we see events
later than we expect.
So what this means,
though, is that we're
going to be seeing multiple
results for that same slice
of event time.
And now we have to answer
our fourth question-- how do
those results refine over time?
In this case, we're going
to use accumulation mode
and just continually
accumulate the scores.
So every time we
see new results,
we'll emit a new cumulative sum
that just continues to grow.
Now we go back to
our graph, and you
can see that we're
getting multiple results
for each slice of event time.
In some windows,
like the second,
we've produced some
early speculative results
as data is still arriving.
Then in every window,
as the watermark passes,
we think we've pretty
much seen it all,
and we emit an on time result.
And finally, if there
are late results,
like in that first window,
we might omit a late updated
element.
And because we
chose to accumulate,
each result that we omit
includes all the elements
for that window, even if
those elements were already
part of a previous result.
So what we did here is
we took an algorithm.
In this case, it was just
simple integer summation.
I could have taken a more
complicated algorithm,
except then I would
have had to animate it,
and these already got
complicated enough.
So we just did
integer sums here,
but it could be a much
more powerful chunk
of user application logic.
And then we tweaked a few lines.
And by changing those other
questions and addressing them,
we were able to cover a
whole number of use cases.
We went from traditional
batch all the way up
through advanced
streaming without having
to change anything about
our algorithm, the what
that we're actually computing.
So just like MapReduce
fundamentally changed the way
that we do data
processing by providing
a new set of abstractions
that allowed us
to reason about these
types of programs,
we think this data
flow model will
change the way we do
batch and streaming
processing in the future
by unifying them together
based on these four questions.
So that's the first
benefit of Cloud Dataflow--
the programming
model and the way
that you write your pipelines.
The second part is the
fully managed service
for executing these pipelines.
This service scales the number
of workers and configures
that throughout pipeline
execution as your data
sizes evolve.
It dynamically schedules work
across your different machines,
and it provides integrated
monitoring and logging.
So between those two--
between the model
and the fully-managed
service-- we've
addressed two of
our three goals,
but we still want to
address portability.
That's where Apache
Beam comes in.
So in late January, we took
the dataflow model and the SDKs
that implement it, and we
developed these in conjunction
with the Manage
Dataflow service.
But along with some partners,
we took this programming model
and donated it to the
Apache Software Foundation
as the incubating project
Apache Beam, which means,
among other things,
we get a new logo.
So here's our snazzy
new logo with two
overlapping beams of light
representing the unification
of batch and stream into beam.
And now we have puns all over.
We're beaming with joy.
The puns never get old.
But what does Apache
Beam actually include?
So it's the programming
model, this idea
of describing your
data processing
in terms of the what,
where, when, and how.
It's the initial job
SDK that we developed
as part of Cloud Dataflow.
And there will be other SDKs,
including Python to follow.
And most importantly,
for portability,
it's the number of
runners that know
how to take a beam
pipeline and execute it
on an existing
distributed back end.
So right now, that
includes runners
that can run a beam pipeline
on Apache Fling, Apache
Spark, and then of course,
the Cloud Dataflow service.
Our goal as we transition the
Dataflow programming model
into Beam over the
next few months
is to fully support three
different categories of users.
We've always focused
on end users.
These are the users
who want to write
data-processing pipelines.
They want that nice, little
Pac-Man from the beginning
where they focus on their
logic and their results
and they don't have to
deal with the other stuff.
They just want to take the
language that they're already
familiar with and run it in
whatever distributed processing
environment is most
convenient for them.
But in addition to those users,
now as part of Apache Beam,
we want to focus on developing
stable APIs and documentation
that are going to allow others
in the open source community
to develop new SDKs
and provide new runners
for alternative distributed
processing environments.
So we're just getting started
growing that community.
JAMES MALONE: So building a
community around Apache Beam
is going to be absolutely
critical to its success.
The community will help
Apache Beam really achieve
the goal of being an open source
platform for next generation
data processing.
But building a community
involves a few key things.
And we're just getting started
building this community.
First, we have to
focus on collaboration.
We were really surprised
when we wrote the Apache Beam
incubating proposal
and submitted it.
There was an outstanding amount
of interest in Apache Beam.
There's also a
lot of groups that
have thrown in
new ideas and ways
that they want to expand
Beam and see Beam grow.
Taking all of this and
collaborating together
so we can take all of the
collective energy and brain
power and needs and
problems that people
want to solve and work together
towards a unified solution
is going to be both a
challenge, but ultimately,
incredibly rewarding.
As Frances mentioned, the
data flow SDK and model
at this point has really
focused on end users.
We want Beam, through
the collaboration,
to also include the SDK
writers and the runner writers.
Now, we want to
grow Apache Beam.
And there's a few people
that may be wondering, why
the Apache Software Foundation.
It's come up in conversations
that I've had with people here.
Ultimately, Apache
Beam is a great fit
for the Apache
Software Foundation
because it will grow within
a community of other data
processing tools.
So as Francis mentioned, there's
a Flink runner and a Spark
runner.
It's not all about just making
Apache Beam awesome and better.
There may be things that we
need to help out on with Spark
or with Flink or other projects.
And as a member of the
Apache software community
and under that umbrella,
we can make that happen.
And that's critically important.
We also want to learn.
And this is Google's first
data-related contribution
to the Apache
Software Foundation.
And we're learning quite a bit.
We're learning the Apache way.
We're also shifting from
Google tools and infrastructure
to those that are used
by Apache Projects.
And we're trying to
take that learning
and apply it, and learn quickly,
and get started quickly,
and move things forward.
So we wrote the
proposal in January,
and we entered incubation
to the Apache incubator
in early February.
To show how serious we are
about really getting started
and making an impact and
moving things forward,
the first commit
to the repository
was in late February.
So we're really
excited to get moving.
Early in 2016-- so
where we are now--
we're really focused on
refactoring and redesign.
We really, really want to
focus on all three of those
use cases-- so the end users,
the runner writers, and the SDK
writers.
That means by mid-year, we're
going to take all of the design
and refactoring and things that
we've come up with, new APIs,
and we're going to
be implementing them
on the Beam project.
It's important to note,
though, that we don't want to
and we will not
interrupt data flow
users who are in this process.
So we're really focused
on improving and making
these updates to
the Beam project.
So towards the end of
the year, the Beam team
can say that Beam pipelines
will run on multiple runners.
You could take a Beam
pipeline and run it reliably
on Flink or Spark.
You could also use the Beam SDK
to articulate Beam pipelines
and run them on the
Cloud Dataflow service.
So with Beam and
Cloud Dataflow, you
start to check all of the
boxes for next generation data
processing.
With Cloud Dataflow, you get
an awesome managed service
where you can send it
pipelines and you don't
worry about infrastructure.
You don't worry about
spinning up servers.
logging and monitoring.
With Beam, you get a portable,
powerful, unified model
that you can use to articulate
data processing pipelines.
So between the two,
you start to end up
in a place that is
truly next generation.
That said, while we think
that Cloud Dataflow is going
to be an awesome place
to run Beam pipelines,
and we think it will
be the best-managed way
to run Beam pipelines, Beam
itself is also portable,
which means that there
are other runners
that you can use to run Beam.
And these runners can exist
in any number of environments.
They might be on premise.
You might want to run
Flink, for instance,
on a cluster in your
local data center.
You might want to run
Spark on another cloud.
That's OK.
These runners may have
varying levels of fidelity
in how they support Beam
based on their own models
and underlying semantics.
But again, going
back to my comment
about being a member of the
Apache Software Foundation,
that's why it's very
important for us
to work together inside
of the Apache umbrella
so we can try and help everybody
out and move everybody forward.
Now, it's getting late.
And if you only remember
a few things from this--
we've been talking for awhile.
If you wake up tomorrow,
and you were like,
that was the best presentation
I've ever seen, please remember
it with the following points.
First, the MapReduce
paper in 2004
kicked off a flurry of activity.
You had two branches that
predominately emerged.
You had one in
Google that continued
to iterate on the
ideas of MapReduce
and create new
papers, and then you
had a whole ecosystem develop
in the open source community.
As a result of
these two branches,
we have two awesome products
that you can use today
in Google Cloud Platform
to take advantage
of the work in these
two work streams.
You have Cloud Dataflow
to take advantage
of all of the awesome iteration
in both infrastructure
and software that Google
invested after MapReduce,
and you have Cloud
Dataproc to take advantage
of all of those components you
could use on Cloud Dataproc
today.
Apache Beam is a bridge
between these two work streams
that split in 2004.
In 2016, we want to
bring them back together.
Apache Beam can be managed.
Using services like
Dataflow, it's very easy
run Beam on Managed Services.
Beam provides a unified
model for batch and stream
processing.
Finally, Beam
pipelines are portable
along different runners.
You can take your Beam
pipelines and run them
on different runners
in different locations.
FRANCES PERRY: Am I on?
There we go.
We hope this talk
leaves you wanting
to learn more about
doing data processing
and open source at Google.
You can go use Cloud
Dataproc today.
You can start spinning up
Hadoop and Spark clusters
and use that
fully-managed service.
If you want to learn about the
dataflow-- now the Beam model--
you can use Dataflow
today to write pipelines
that run on Cloud Dataflow.
And over time, as we
finish bootstrapping,
you'll be able to use
Apache Beam to run
those same pipelines anywhere.
Well, thank you very much.
James and I will be
around, so please come
find us, ask questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]